I was in LA last week and I was saying
as I'm not in LA hater
people have asked me why don't you move
to LA over the years I've just never
gone and I was there last week and I had
this realization where and it's nothing
as the city or the industry but just me
personally I showed up there I was there
for four or five days and I was like oh
when I am here I want to be dead like I
just I want to be dead when I'm in this
city something about the city makes me
want to because it's a fine place full
of nice people and warm weather and all
my friends are happy there and I'm not
trying to come down on the city because
that's a little cliche and it's not it's
not what I'm going for it's just on a
personal level within 36 hours of
arriving in Los Angeles California I
will find myself praying for death
[Music]
welcome back to the show in studio
joining us right now is Chris Gethard he
has a new book out called lose well
Chris when did this come out I don't
have any information in front of me okay
I'm out Tuesday Tuesday is this your
second book third book third book I
never slow down Wow why how do you still
have something to write about what are
we writing about in this one now this
one is it's a bunch of funny stories and
stuff but it all kind of ties into the
idea that the older I get the more I
think failure is actually a really good
thing we were just talking about this it
served me really well in my life tell me
Wow
and when did you come to this conclusion
a lot of it happened in 2010 because as
you guys know as comedians and I try to
write this in a broad way where it will
not just appeal to comedians artists but
you know you spend so much time thinking
about your success relative to other
people's and I was coming up in a scene
at UCB where everyone was getting super
successful and I was not and I had all
this feelings of like why is it not
happening for me all the stress and then
I finally got a sitcom and then the
sitcom bombed and I didn't care and I
was like why don't I care and then I was
like oh I don't like sitcoms why did I
view it as success to be on one that was
very much driven by pettiness and ego
this feeling that I wanted things that
other people had who cares and that's
when I went to public access TV yeah and
kind of built my career and a beacon
Chris Gethard show yeah and it became
this thing people were like really
passionate about
before and by anyone's actually I think
by anyone's standard definition of
success a public access show is not
successful compared to a sitcom lead the
lead but for me it felt very much like
success and I completely relate to that
because you get these opportunities and
you go yes and you just say yes because
that's its Jane that's what that's what
people get when I see them talk about it
on Twitter and everyone makes a big deal
and that's what's that's when you've
made it but then I'm like I don't want
to do that every day with my lip do I
really want that like we don't ask that
enough and so you weren't bummed out
when you're so askance I mean you were
me it's done it's done yes it was
humiliating to get really bad reviews on
my acting ability but I was sitting
there and I was like yeah but I also
don't care and I'm someone who's so
prone to depression and stuff that I
thought it was gonna kill me I was like
oh hey I largely don't care and I just
realized it's all ego get the ego in
another way yeah that is a scary thing
is that you just said you thought it
would kill you because when you put
yourself out there and you set yourself
up to have a disappointment like that
you're like oh this could what if this
kills me right I'm gonna keep doing this
to myself yeah what is it that I
actually love about it let me go focus
on that that's what I've learned it's
like the reai I keep putting myself in
these situations cuz I have to and if I
have to do I better just get out there
and do it and own it and if it doesn't
work out I gotta be okay with that yeah
that's that's the tough part I did
Dancing with the Stars and I was so
scared that now how would you like it I
don't think I've seen you succeed I
loved it I wish I was still on I
I loved it more than I thought I would
it was one of the greatest experiences
of my life I'm dying to get back on I'm
gonna reap I'm gonna pitch to them that
they do a loser season with everyone
who's been eliminated first that's a
great idea
I just I loved it and I didn't expect to
love it and I did it just because I was
like oh that you get asked to do it I
kind of wanted a break from my life to
be honest because when you do Dancing
with the Stars you can't do anything
else so you're just like I couldn't do
stand-up at night I couldn't I honestly
took it as a vacation and I say
and people think I'm creepy I never ever
I'm quietly a very good dancer you are
literally if they ever ask you to do it
to it it's look great it's the greatest
thing I've ever done it was so fun I
think that we do have to often ask
ourselves that because we just get it in
our head what success is I think we all
don't we all relate to that of like you
guess like that yeah yeah comparing
yourself how do we stop doing it Chris
how do you have you stopped comparing
yourself by how by doing stuff that very
few people care about but the ones who
do care about it are very passionate
about it you know I don't have the most
fans but I think I have some of the best
fans yes and I've just constantly
doubled down on doing stuff that I think
is like a little smaller and a little
bit more reflective of who I am and a
lot of times I found that when you get
to platforms that are very big that
represent a big success it also means
that your stuff gets taken away from you
and taken away from your voice and I
think I've just been very very willing
to get up and walk away from the table
in those situations and that helps me
not compare myself you know what do you
do to get out of that have you had the
moments like that oh yeah absolutely and
you just don't have them anymore
well no ever going down spiral and
seeing someone kill or hearing that
someone killed or gets hearing someone
get something that you would avoid
certainly time I will say this like we
all do there are certainly times where
how do you say it delicately I mean you
don't there's certainly times where you
see people where you're like that
person's not that good yes and that's a
different thing to me because you're
like this is this is their hoodwinking
the audience it's snake-oil and that's
bad for all of us they go and see some
show where it's like oh they went in on
the hype and the person's not that good
that means they don't buy tickets for
coming yeah I don't like that
the dangerous part is when it's someone
who I don't have anything against or
it's even a friend of mine that's when
it gets really insidious you know when
it's like oh this is a person I'll sit
down ask them how they're doing mean it
care about their answers I know that
when they ask me they mean it too and
then when they go and do well I'm gonna
be like screw them you know what I mean
like that's when it becomes really
insidious
and I have managed you away there and I
think a lot of it is just because I can
say so honestly that most of the
situations in my life that were
traditional success did nothing but add
stress or unhappiness and there's been a
lot of situations where I've landed I've
landed in in circumstances that very
much by other people's definitions were
failure and they made me happy so I've
just kind of learned to say who cares I
think like you say I think for you you
have to deal with a patriarchy driven
version of it but for me I think even in
a broad sense for a lot of us it's sort
of like I think culture and society just
trains you to want to like feel like you
have to stay in your lane you know yeah
stay in your cubicle I'm not
allowed to curse sorry yes yes it's like
stay in your cubicle I always
felt like somewhere people who are like
you know you're meant to be seen and not
heard like I don't come from a family of
artists or our neighborhood of artists
that constantly felt like it was like oh
you think you're better than us like
wanting to go do that like that was
always the vibe and I just don't buy it
I just don't buy it
and I feel like I do I've done a lot of
things that are sort of like smaller for
very few people and they make me
immensely happy and then I've been in
big movies or performed in front of
thousands of people where I'm like that
was totally fine who cares or it just
makes me a little glum
so I think a lot of how I managed to
avoid worrying about other people's
stuff is remembering that it has
literally no effect on mine doesn't it
doesn't and when I see other people get
jealous of other people I get mad at
them but it's really me getting mad at
myself about being jealous like I just
it's one it's I've never gotten anything
from being jealous not one time I don't
think it's made me work harder I don't
think it's made me work better it is
only made me it's like what I was
talking about last week I lost my purse
and I just had it I was just kind of
like oh well that sucks I'll I'll either
find it or I won't but there's nothing I
can do right now as opposed to wing you
idiot why did you lose your purse like
you're such a stupid bitch like which is
what I would usually do which is never
helped anyone find anything is calling
themselves a stupid bitch but that's
what I feel like I do when I get jealous
of people I got social media too I mean
do you avoid that it's a nightmare it's
a complete nightmare it's a night it
went from a thing that connects us all
that was really beautiful and exciting
to a thing that only brings out the most
in human sides of people yeah I I think
it's we've obviously been saying this
for years now about how it's we all got
to get off it and it makes us compare
ourselves yeah but it is reached a point
where it's it makes me depressed oh for
sure I see a poster you're like oh that
just ruined my day and I don't even care
like if I this the world is the exact
same whether I see this post or not
because I looked at it and like ate
those feelings now I'm just gonna be
thinking about that I hate it well I
posted that video of my dad and mom
singing last night and mark Normand said
I his comment was like I I look at your
parents and wish I had that relationship
with mine and I was like you only see
what I post that's the thing we don't
love when people do do those posts or
they're like it's only fair I post the
good things here's something I failed
that somebody did that the other day I
was like I love that but I wrote I wrote
that and then my dad wrote underneath it
he wrote like wow I don't ever post a
video of me being like you mom and
slamming a door but that happens and
that's I I do appreciate you so much
Chris Gethard because you are just
you're just so honest and try to be
although I do feel bad that I came in
here and this instantly got like way too
philosophical and depressing depressing
is this like a self-help book is this
your version is my version oh yeah I was
so Harper won one of the editors saw my
HBO special mm-hmm as you know focused
on a lot of very dark stuff with my
mental health yes and they asked me to
write a book version of it I said I
don't want to be the depression guy
forever and they said well we really
want to work with you and I found it an
interesting challenge to be contracted
to write a book by a self-help
company and I'd like to think that it's
not snake oil or it's basically
just stuff where I'm like I've been
doing this for 18 years and here's a
bunch of stuff I learned that worked for
me good luck to you and yeah it's a
weirdly pessimistic self-help book which
I'm kind of proud of like over and over
gonna make it's probably not gonna work
don't convince yourself it is 99% chance
that you don't get where you're trying
to go but I just don't think that that's
a bad thing so I felt comfortable
writing it I don't think anybody's gonna
be convinced by by me going here's the
way to get to your dreams but I think
they'll be convinced by me going hey I'm
a guy with weird instincts who has a
giant forehead who often thinks that he
looks like a monster man who has
somehow still managed to work for 18
years and survive at the thing he wanted
to do like even though I'm admittedly
never the funniest comedian in the room
it's like well how did I do that that's
the stuff that might actually help
regular people that's what I want to
read that's what I would have been eager
to consume if you or anyone in your life
feels that way where they're like
they're you know you know you have a
talent but you you might not have the
confidence or you might think how am I
gonna make it this is the book to get
that person or to get yourself lose well
is Chris Gethard book and he is someone
that you just yet you've figured out a
way to to you you have a strong your
brand is strong thank you my brand is I
think we all started out in this
business trying to be someone else who
were you trying to be before you became
Chris Gethard well I was I was at UCB in
2000 you know and you know whatever
people think of it today some people
have issues with the place I was there
when no one had ever heard of it and
exploded and it was this like punk rock
thing and everybody so I was seeing like
very very good friends of mine wind up
on SNL wind up on sitcoms and I was like
I want that meanwhile I was doing all
these shows in New York that I like I
was I was doing shows where comedians
were like if you weren't funny enough
you'd get shot with a paintball gun
onstage or like a bunch of us boxed
each other oh yeah I show still doing
some of these you know a show where I
rented a bus and took people around New
Jersey and told them stories from my
life and
and everybody was like oh you do all the
weird stuff and I would just kind of
like constantly apologize for that
apologize apologize apologize in back no
no no that's not all I do because in my
mind I'm like no I'm gonna go get an SNL
or sitcom job just like everybody else
from UCB i'ma hit a certain point where
I write about it in the book a good
friend of mine sat me down and was like
when are you gonna realize that although
you're the one who does all the weird
stuff and you're the best one at it and
just own that like why do you want to go
get a job just like the jobs everyone
else are getting go do the paintball
thing you know I spent four years on
public access with a TV show that was
aimed at trying to do that and it wasn't
always easy to be on public access but
then it eventually had 47 episodes on
cable like that's nothing to sneeze at
and so much of it was just by saying
yeah I'm not destined for those other
things let other people have those
things I do that a lot with like you
know oh I remember the first time this
like struck me was either watching a
Chappelle special or a Bill burr special
that I just really was like wow that was
tight and there was there was something
about it that made me think I don't know
that I'll ever get to that level of just
brilliance and kind of being like you
know what though they probably don't
have as good of friends as I do like I'm
really good at picking people as friends
so I'm kind of like the Chapelle of like
friendship like I I like my point is
finding what you are good at like you're
good at the weird stuff yeah and I said
you're the best at it and like finding
that yeah but when you do comedy you
just look at like the comedy greats and
you're like what if I don't write the
best one-liners look at much if you
compare yourself to Mitch Hedberg or
Dave Chappelle or never gonna end well
it's never gonna end well but what are
you the best at and I'm not saying that
like having friends is like a as is a
comedic achievement but I was like what
do i what am I really good at what if I
could say that I am like the best set
and I'm like oh I think picking people
to be front like I just have the
greatest friends and so for a while I
was like whenever I get down I'd be like
we'll just remember that your talent is
that and then I there's other
things that I'm good at too that I've
discovered along the way but I think
that that might be kind of a trick if
you're listening and you're like you
compare yourself and you go I'll never
look like that I'll never be that well
what is it could be like a weird thing
but you're better at something than they
are making videos
no Carmen Lynch I mean like you you're
definitely someone I look at that I'm
like well I could never do just I could
never be there there's ton that's you
can and you will be a mermaid I'll never
have a ten-year-old stepson type person
to teach me but do you common do you
relate to this like how do you deal with
yeah it's weird competition silence I
want I have to check in with myself and
be like what do you really want and I
love travelling more than anything like
I want to see the world but I also love
stand-up comedy so if I get an email
that says do you want to do a packet for
such-and-such show it feels very strange
to be like I don't yeah yes you know and
and it's weird to say that to like your
agent or something and there are some
packets that I will do but some of them
I'm like no because if I do this show
then I can't go to you know wherever at
the last minute yeah yeah right well
where is this someone said to you like
do you want to come do a show in
Kazakhstan and we can only pay you $800
I went to Pakistan last year I'm going
to Greenland night next month like I was
in Greenland yeah and ice it doesn't
even pay that much but I'm like I want
to see what that's like
how do you even find those gigs so that
one's for the troops that's a military
thing but you know it's like if if if I
want to show that I don't really want to
write for it but it's you know I should
write for a show because that's what you
do in this career and then you get to
tell people you're right about that show
then that's you get to have it as part
of your Twitter bio right yeah here's
another thing I'll say on this whole
topic and this is not a reference to any
names that have come up thus far but I
think we can all agree that kind of
being in the trenches and being around
people not always but often enough some
of the most successful people I've seen
who
from the outside people if those are the
superstars from my perspective seem to
be intensely lonely yeah
intensely lonely and not thrilled with
how they know that's like exactly what I
was I said this a few weeks ago but I I
believe like sometimes if you are
jealous of someone you go what I trade
lives with them though and I almost
never would like that so many people
like I wouldn't want to walk around like
that with that voice yes because and I
think Tom you're more in this part of
your career than any of us because we've
been around longer but like you're
getting opportunity is now placed in
front of you that it's like auditions
for shows yeah or writing packets or and
and they come across you and you go oh
my god like I can't not throw my hat in
the ring for ya like like you were just
saying and you got it I am so glad I
didn't get some of the jobs that I went
out yeah yeah so glad because and my
therapist taught me this a million times
when you say no to something you're
saying yes to everything else that means
any that means everything yeah so when
you saying no can be very powerful
I'm just I didn't say no a lot but I
wish I would have because if I would
have gotten any of those jobs I wouldn't
have this yeah and who's to say if I
would have said no to this I could be
somewhere even better but I don't that's
a good point
it really is it's hard to turn down
things especially when you're a comic
and you just have to say yes to
everything
up front but man there were some things
that I cried over not getting and I look
back and I'm like that would have been
miserable and all I really wanted was
the line in my Twitter bye
that's it for sure when I first moved
here I was there was writing jobs where
I was like devastated that I didn't get
then I watched the show after I was like
I don't even like this yeah I don't even
like this show why would I want you
would not be able to do Santa but yeah
that's or you would and you would be
sleepless like you were in college
working - gags I mean yeah it's some of
the things you look back on that you
didn't get it's usually a good thing he
was a guest writer at SNL in 2007 four
nights
two weeks over I am a dream job dream
job and I realize I was so so devastated
to not get hired afterwards I got a
sketch to dress rehearsal I was like I'm
on this inside track didn't get hire
devastate but I look back at who I was
in 2007 and I look at what that job
demands of people and I realize I would
be dead I would have started drinking
again
I would I would have become addicted to
drugs I know myself I know where I was I
know that pace I know I would not have
been able to handle that at the age of
26 27 I would be dead if I wasn't dead I
would be a vastly different person I
would have chewed me up and spat me out
thank God I didn't get it and it was the
dream job at the time and I cried and
tried I've submitted I think for three
or four years after that being like how
did I drop the ball how did I and it was
like this great white whale that was
eating me up I failed at this so you
know if I had gotten this I would have
become like a cokehead I know I would
have I know I would have I yeah I I
agree with you if I would have gotten
some of the things that were big
opportunities early on I wouldn't have
been able to get sober and I'd probably
be dead yeah I probably be and not
saying that everyone needs to find
sobriety and that's what's the solution
is not for me but for our case for my
mental stability needed to not be
successful until I was ready for it and
thank God I wasn't oh yeah because it
would have been you know well you see it
happen all the time people get
successful to get these opportunities
too young and you squander them I mean
in 2012 it was five years later and I
tried adderall once and it led to a real
bad summer you know like really money
2007 I would have been even less acquit
oh yeah
dangerous yeah I was I started eating
like 60 milligrams a day
whoa nuts I lost a ton of weight oh yeah
that's stayed up all night it was crazy
yeah you might lose weight on adderall
but the thing that has kept me from
doing is that it ages you yeah because
your eyes are like huh and so you get
crow's feet faster don't let go tiny
side effects what I pooped blood what
and you were just like
yet I didn't go to a doctor frightfully
long time but that is that bad should I
be concerned staying up all night and
act like a crazy person yeah at that
point pooping blood whatever yeah I was
they were bigger officially I ate a
bunch of beets a couple days ago you
started
[Laughter]
[Music]
you